hey guys I'm the successful YouTuber you  didn't know existed until you clicked on  this video I'm here to tell you how I  gained 14 million subscribers in just  two days  and so can you most YouTubers will give  you the standard advice of be consistent  find your Niche reply to comments well  I'm not like other YouTubers so I'm  going to tell you basically the same  information but in different words  instead of being consistent find your  instead of finding your Niche make  videos you're passionate about instead  of replying the comments bond with your  view now that we're near the end of the  video here's a random superstitious tip  that I have that I think helps videos in  the algorithm never put an M Dash in  your title  it's poison for retention heard that  somewhere 60 of success on YouTube is  hard work the other ninety percent is  luck and it really it really scares me  the universe is chaotic and I'm scared